as well
this Bank thing to see all these Banks
what oh this is kind of scary right the
Silicon Valley Bank went down and the
signature bank and Credit Suisse the big
Swiss bank and First Republic needs a
bailout now I'd say there's never been a
better time to have no money at all
that Signature Bank one that was the one
that was way into crypto and that's when
you know you're a bad Bank when you
don't you you run out of imaginary money
that's
but uh
the Republicans have figured out why the
banks went under they were too woke I'm
not kidding that's what they're saying
now look I'm no fan of woke but come on
even my dog has more than one bark
I like they were having drag queen
deposit hour
[Laughter]
apropo apropos of this sort of do you
see there's a 5 000 mile long blob of
seaweed
oh I know heading for it's going to hit
the beaches in Florida and I'm just
waiting for DeSantis to say well the
ocean is too woke
and uh
it's it's shocking what fish are
learning in their schools
no I don't
know I don't have this country keeps
going
with so much nuttiness here's something
that I found very interesting today new
poll so it shows that uh two-thirds of
Republicans Republican voters think that
their own party the Republicans worked
secretly with with the Liberals
[Laughter]
to make Biden president I mean of all
the conspiracy theories that is the
craziest bipartisanship
I'll believe a lot of things
and on the other side of crazy did you
see that what the San Francisco
supervisors have done they are backing
reparations uh if you're a black person
in San Francisco of five million dollars
really nothing no reaction okay all
right let me keep going if I you get
five million dollars elimination of
personal debt of all tax burdens a
guaranteed annual income of ninety seven
thousand dollars for 250 years wow must
be some Health Care involved there too
and a home that you get for one dollar
and the uh
[Applause]
let's see who's clapping there
the first to comment on this was George
Santos who said as a black man
thank you